le pôle juridique à pourrait fermer ses
portes courant 2016 la structure
gérontologique situe à magny les hameaux
fait face à des difficultés financières
le centre spécialisé dans l'aide aux
personnes en perte d'autonomie affiche
un déficit de 40 mille euros la raison
le loyer demandé par saint quentin en
yvelines le propriétaire des lieux
seraient trop élevés ce loyer donc
correspond en quelque sorte un loyer
donc pour une structure marchande des
gens qui effectivement font un travail
qui dans lequel ils gagnent beaucoup
d'argent
ici nous sommes dans une structure
sociale effectivement donc on gagne pas
d'argent
aujourd'hui la situation est compliquée
d'autant que certains partenaires se
retire donc là l'effort qui va être
porté par l'agglomération
da c'est tout simplement de dire que on
va essayer de trouver un nouveau loyer
pour que tous ceux qui pillent qui
souhaitent rester dans gironde et gap
puis ceux de fermer aux conditions que
nous avons fixés si aucun accord n'est
trouvé le centre pourrait fermer ses
portes au mois de juin
sept postes seront alors supprimer une
vingtaine de patients devront trouver
une nouvelle structure d'accueil
c'est inhumain je dis franchement si
inhumain alors qu'on une sécurité qui
est magique qui y correspond donc à
quelque chose qui est est donc vécue et
qui reconnut reconnu je me battrai pour
que ça ne ferme pas une réunion pourrait
être programmé dans les prochaines
semaines entre les membres de gironde
icap et les responsables de
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise